We all have fond memories of the playground.
Hours upon hours spent in blissful childhood
abandon, racing around the local park, climbing
the monkey bars, and seeing if you could get
even higher on the swings than your best friend.
And then, of course, there’s the slide.
Who doesn’t love a slide?
Only you and the force of gravity pulling
you down through a straight or a spiral tube.
Those few seconds of excitement, that rush
of not knowing whether you’ll come out the
other end of the slide or not, that’s enough
of a thrill for any kid.
Of course, you would always come tumbling
out of the mouth of the slide every time,
at worst, with an odd but innocent friction
burn on your leg or arm.
But what if, one day, you didn’t come out
of the other end?
Or worse, what if the place at the end of
the slide wasn’t the world you left behind
when you slid through the entrance?
It doesn’t seem all that likely to happen,
right?
Well, you’ve obviously never taken a trip
down SCP-1562, better known as the Tunnel
Slide.
As its moniker suggests, SCP-1562 is a slide.
Or, it at least appears to be an ordinary
tunnel slide.
You know, the kind you would easily find at
any kids’ park, jungle gym, or indoor play
area.
Just over two meters high and almost three
and a half meters long.
And for the most part, it is a completely
normal slide.
If you were to just sit in it and glide down
it, feet first, nothing would happen.
Then again, if SCP-1562 was an ordinary, everyday
piece of a playground, then the SCP Foundation
would not have such a vested interest in it.
They definitely wouldn’t be keeping it locked
up in quarantine, secured in Testing Lab 46-V
of Site 24 - and if any Foundation agents
ask, you didn’t hear that from us, by the
way.
The door to the lab is kept locked at all
times, no member of personnel is even allowed
near the slide unless granted special clearance
to do so by Foundation researcher, Doctor
Carver.
So, what is it that makes this thing so special?
Well, for one, SCP-1562 was first recovered
by the Foundation from a defunct, abandoned
playground.
The location of this playground has been redacted,
but it was known to be on the outskirts of
a town where a number of young children had
been reported missing.
Does SCP-1562 contain some sort of clue as
to where these children were taken?
Perhaps some piece of forensic evidence left
behind by a child-snatching anomaly from another
dimension?
Not quite.
SCP-1562 is the thing that took those children.
You see, the slide’s anomalous properties
require very specific circumstances in order
to activate.
Like we mentioned earlier, if you were just
sitting on your butt while you were sliding
down it, you would escape unscathed.
Laying flat on your back?
That is also a safe option.
Even flailing yourself about, spinning and
rolling and waving your arms, changing position
on the way down would mean that nothing anomalous
would appear to happen.
However, if someone enters SCP-1562 and travels
down in head first, laying on their stomach
with their arms tucked at their side, almost
in a plank position, then that is when strange
things start to happen.
That is when a person finds out what happened
to those missing children.
Only about fifteen centimeters from the opening
of the slide, a person sliding down on their
front, head first, with arms by their sides,
will disappear right before exiting SCP-1562.
In an instant, they will simply be gone, no
longer in the slide or even relocated to anywhere
nearby.
To make matters worse, every single person
that this has happened to has never been found
again.
They literally have vanished off the face
of the Earth.
Unfortunately, there isn’t much that can
be done to prevent this.
During testing, the Foundation quickly learned
that tethering a safety line to a subject
does little to stop them from disappearing.
They cannot be pulled back from wherever it
is that the slide sends them.
The rope they are attached to is simply cut
and goes slack from the moment that a person
is taken by the slide.
Now, that sounds like the whole story, right?
Children are going missing, and the Foundation
learns it’s because of SCP-1562, some kind
of interdimensional portal within a playground
slide.
So, they acquire the slide, take it away and
keep it locked up securely where it can’t
cause any more disappearances, end of story.
Except that’s not quite the end.
No, the one thing it’s still possible to
do once someone has disappeared down the slide
is to stay in contact with them.
The SCP Foundation has expended a number of
test subjects by sending them sliding down
SCP-1562, just to learn what’s on the other
side.
Just where does the slide take them?
Luckily, tests like this are precisely what
the Foundation has D Class personnel for.
So, what happened when the Foundation sent
some D-Classes on a one-way joyride down the
slide?
Well, one test involved a D-Class designated
D-2445, who disappeared into SCP-1562 but
was given a two-way radio to communicate directly
with Doctor Darritz, one of the research staff.
D-2445 reported that he found himself in a
small, cramped tunnel, and quickly requested
to be let back out.
Doctor Darritz had neglected to tell D-2445
that was impossible, and that no one ever
came back from inside the slide.
While it was too dark to see anything, the
prisoner described still being laid on his
front but feeling like there were rocks or
dirt surrounding him on all sides.
Realizing that he barely had enough room to
move, or even lift his head, D-2445 again
requested to be let out of SCP-1562.
As the unfortunate D-Class grew increasingly
more unsettled by the movement-restricting
environment, Doctor Darritz revealed that
the lifeline tethering D-2445 back to the
Foundation had been severed upon their disappearance
into the slide.
Panicking, D-2445 managed to move forward
slightly and realized that his head had hit
something: a shoe.
A tiny, child’s shoe.
Communication with D-2445 was called to a
halt, and the Foundation’s researchers discussed
possible ways they could retrieve the prisoner.
Although most of them probably knew at this
point that this task was likely impossible,
this test may have taken place before the
Foundation realized that return from SCP-1562
was impossible.
The plan was that another D-Class would be
sent into the slide.
Once again, they would be attached to a tether
line and be carrying video and audio recording
equipment, along with a GPS tracker, and a
headlamp.
Reaching out to D-2445, Doctor Darritz relayed
this plan to him.
D-2445 immediately begged to be set free from
SCP-1562, as the doctor attempted to calm
him down, but to little effect.
Something had scared him, truly terrified
him, a sound coming from somewhere within
the tunnel.
“It started talking” D-2445 claimed.
When Doctor Darritz asked for clarity, the
D-Class replied, saying that a little boy
had tried to speak to him, but that the child
had made little sense.
“He just kept asking where he was, and I
told him I didn't know.
But I don't think he was really talking to
me, because he didn't respond to my voice,
and he told me to stop crying when I was actually
sort of calm.”
When asked if this child had moved at all,
D-2445 said that he was unsure.
“He started screaming and I told him to
shut up but he just kept screaming and crying
and asking for his mommy.
Then he finally stopped, and shortly after
that, you contacted me again.
Please get me out now.”
Doctor Darrtiz tried to reassure the man,
to little avail, and communication with D-2445
was cut off after he claimed something was
wrong with his chest.
Shortly after the Foundation lost communication
with D-2445, another member of D Class was
sent into the slide after him.
This subject, referred to officially as D-8600,
had been specifically selected for this task
thanks to his small stature.
Doctor Darrtiz and the other Foundation researchers
testing SCP-1562 believed that the man’s
thinner body type would allow D-8600 to better
navigate the tunnel that the slide seemed
to transport people to.
And you can probably guess what happened next.
Just like all the others that had been sent
down the slide, D-8600 was trapped.
His lifeline was cut the moment that he vanished
inside the tunnel slide.
On top of this, the GPS tracker that this
thinner D Class had been issued with seemed
to not be working properly.
Its signal could not be correctly traced,
and without an accurate fix, there was no
way to determine the location to which SCP-1562
was transporting its victims - if it was even
in this universe.
Additionally, the video feed to the camera
D-8600 was carrying also failed to connect,
with only audio from his radio being recovered
by the research team.
Contacting D-8600, Doctor Darritz was informed
by this new D Class that his headlamp had
stopped working the second he had arrived
in the same cave or tunnel as earlier test
subjects.
Before long, by shimmying through the area
on his arms, D-8600 bumped into a foot, believed
to be belonging to D-2445.
While he could barely see anything, D-8600
could hear D-2445’s voice, and this was
being faintly picked up via his radio.
However, as he and Doctor Darritz tried to
talk to the first prisoner, his words began
to sound all too familiar.
“I don't know.
Some sort of very small tunnel.
It's really cramped.
Can you get me out now?”
followed by “No, it's too dark.
I can't see anything, and I'm stuck.”
It was all just a recording of what D-2445
had said when he’d first arrived after SCP-1562
had sent him into the tunnel.
D-8600 did not realize this at first and attempted
to help his fellow prisoner, hoping to pull
him out of wherever they were trapped.
Doctor Darritz tried desperately to explain
that D-2445 was just repeating his half of
an earlier conversation, but D-8600 hardly
noticed that was the case.
He gripped the other D Class’ ankles and
told the doctor to pull them out of the tunnel.
The doctor revealed that once again the tether
line had been severed, but D-8600 refused
to believe that escape was impossible.
He tried to worm his way back the way he had
come, leaving D-2445 still repeating his words
from earlier.
“He just kept asking where he was, and I
told him I didn't know.
But I don't think he was really talking to
me, because he didn't respond to my voice,
and he told me to stop crying when I was actually
sort of calm…
I don't think so.
He started screaming and I told him to shut
up but he just kept screaming and crying and
asking for his mommy.
Then he finally stopped, and shortly after
that, you contacted me again.
Please get me out now…Please hurry, my chest
is really starting to hurt.”
After yelling at him to stop talking multiple
times, D-8600 noted that D-2445 had finally
gone quiet.
The D Class also remarked that the air was
starting to taste stale, and hoped that there
would be enough oxygen for him to get back.
Then, just like his predecessor, communication
with D-8600 came to an abrupt stop.
Doctor Darritz was no longer able to reach
him on the radio, there was nothing but static.
The Foundation was unable to re-establish
contact with either of the two D Class personnel
lost inside SCP-1562, and any future testing
of the Tunnel Slide was suspended.
To this day, none of us know what exactly
happened to the victims of the tunnel slide.
Where were they taken?
What had taken them?
What was making the prior victims repeat their
ominous words?
As horror author Stephen King once put it,
“It’s the unanswered question that stays
with us the longest.”
But the next time you decide to thrill your
inner child by taking a jaunt to your local
kiddie park, you may just find out for yourself…
Now go check out “SCP-3001 - Red Reality”
and “Trapped in a Game - SCP-1733 - Season
Opener” for more horrifying anomalous places
you’d really hate to be trapped inside!